okay well welcome everybody I'm glad to
see some familiar faces only familiar
faces this time I'm going to quickly
introduce myself for people who are
watching online I'm Robin 21 years old
I'm from the Netherlands there's going
to be my second lecture on video and
you've already seen several of my
lectures so welcome today mastering the
middlegame today I want to discuss
perhaps my favourite game and the first
question is very simple before we get
started how do you play the perfect game
as black and you know you might think
that's a subjective question and there's
not a clear answer but to me there is a
pretty clear answer so does anyone have
a suggestion how do you play the perfect
game as black you want to prevent all
whites threats it's that's part of it
surely but it's easier than that you
need to play the Kings Indian not so
difficult that's the first thing you
need to do I mean I like I said it's a
slightly subjective opinion but in my
personal opinion as a professional chess
player you need to play the King's
Indian to get the perfect game going now
I've been a King's Indian player for a
couple years I would say and what I love
most of all about this opening is that
you can play it against c4 d4 Knight f3
and you just have a whole repertoire
against so many different moves that you
might struggle with the people ate a
green flower or Slav no real move order
issues there so previously I had a
lecture in which I beat ding Lyra and I
show my game which I won against him and
that was not very nice of me because
normally I wouldn't be the player of
that caliber so today I'm going to
explain a little bit why I actually
showed that game it's because ding
leerin is one of my favourite players
and the reason for that is that I think
especially in the last 5 or 10 years
even though he's not a pure King's
Indian player anymore he's one of the
few stars who really rose playing this
opening
and just doing an amazing job and this
game specifically to me made such a big
impression that when this was played in
Chung Dow open 2011 against the Leyland
pond celaya
I was just very happy about the opening
I just picked that I was a grand mess I
was just becoming a grandmaster at the
time or I just turned a grandmaster and
I saw this game and I was like yes this
is the opening for me and I'm glad that
I've been studying this so what we're
going to do it's going to be a quiz
format some of you are already familiar
with that but basically we're going to
go to several critical positions I'm
going to offer you three different
choices and I suggest the people online
also take part you post a video or
something like that and we're going to
discuss either the most the right move
or preferably if we have time all of
them move shortly and through through
doing that we're going to go through the
entire game so let's start off so like I
said the Kings Indian he's playing
Knight of three c4 we don't know exactly
what he wants but we're playing King's
Indian we don't really have to worry
about it so he goes for the g3 variation
and this is a position that I play quite
regularly with black I play to move a
six which is also played in the game
this is the panel variation and in this
game or in this position white has
several options at this pose we can go
b3 recently Bishop to f4 is very popular
h3 is a move but the main line is d5 and
what I I'm not sure whether what I'm
about to say is correct but what I think
is the case is that this variation was
not so popular anymore after this
specific game at least after seeing this
game from the black side I would no
longer go for this line if this was in
my white repertoire okay
so nice a five-night to d2y protects the
c4 pawn and c5 this is really kind of a
VI like this is where all the games go
black lace e5 of course you needed to
prevent b4 and now basically what the
problem is is that we're stuck with this
let's say arguably weeknight on on a
five it's not very well placed but we
have some play on the queen-size some of
you may have seen games here Brooke to
be a B 5 etc and the first question is
actually as early as here this is
actually a mainline mainline position
that I'm about to ask you about so I'm
going to give you three options we have
worked the b8 preparing b5 we have e six
playing in the center and we have b5
immediately I'm going to give you two
three minutes it's really more of a
matter of taste more than anything so
think about this for a second rook to b8
b5 & e6
okay it's really an intuitive decision
at this point so has everyone been able
to make up their mind alright which
moves do we have in mind who wants to
play rook to b8 first of all okay to b5
okay
it's very stubborn as usual Andi six so
six okay
well we have really divided groups over
here so first of all Brooke tb8 is the
main line so if you choose rook b8
there's nothing wrong with your pick
ecigs
I'm not a huge fan of we can have a
quick look let's say e6 b3 takes takes
we get kind of a Benoni position over
here this is what you were aiming for b5
Bishop to b2 and I personally don't like
the fact that he's been able to put the
bishop here even though we've been able
to expand on the Queen side we had we
don't really have targets over here
normally you know black would aim to
play b4 let's say if we go B for now
then most likely what's going to regroup
something like this and immediately get
back to the c-4 square so of course it's
not really a huge advantage for white
but my theory is considered to be
slightly better this position so e six
is playable it's not the best move rook
to b8 is the main line and as you can
probably guess by now
he played b5 that's correct so rip the
b8 why is it that I don't like this move
well it has to do everything with what I
pointed out earlier I don't like the
1985 the main line over here runs b3 b5
Bishop to b2 and really what black is
hoping for is something related to
tactics against the c-4 pawn may be a
potential sacrifice on b2 but somehow it
feels wrong to me that we're playing on
the side of the board where our worst
place pieces you know is on a 5 and if
white manages to consolidate this
position and of course there have been
you know power of games and great
players going for this they play
something like e 5 here and it's it's
very complicated but at the end of the
day fundamentally I just don't like this
position because if white plays it well
my night is never going to be
truly an active piece you can imagine if
it's not working out on a five it might
have to go back to be seven one day and
well nobody likes to have an item B 7 in
this position so it's really it's really
more of a mindset thing then then
something concrete as a Kings Indian
player I prefer more dynamic positions
and ding Liron in this game goes for b5
which at the time really wasn't known to
be a very good move so let's see what
did he have what do you have in mind
because clearly he played this with some
preparation with some ideas which you
know went a little further than the
current then the theory at the time set
so next question very good
you've lost upon what do we do next do
we play Bishop to a6 this is very much
in like Benko gambit style where the
bishop usually goes to a6
do we play Queen to b6 develop the Queen
and leave the you know the faith of the
bishop
you know undecided for now or do we play
Bishop to b7 putting the pressure on d5
so again two three minutes and we'll
discuss the options okay
the main the main issue for me after
Bishop to b7 is that I simply don't know
what to do after Knight to c3 because
the knight probably is going to go back
to c3 and well okay we cannot really
attack the pawn another time right so
why put the Bishop on b7 basically Queen
b6 is the right move is there anyone who
has another move no okay is there
anything you
yeah I like your basics okay
Bishop to a6 is fine but after let's say
Knight to c3 okay very good points
because it's not so clear at all I'm
what I'm saying once again is very
general so that brings us to the next
question
Queen to b6 was plays Knight to c3 is
the most logical move after a for what
is the problem with a 4 over here is
there a problem
once again the Banco gambit is not it
even though it might have a sort of a
name as a very tactical opening a lot of
it is positional ideas really the idea
here is that if I go Bishop to d7 now
for example Knight to c3 back you're a
bit stuck here imagine I go rook to b8
what you would like to do is somehow
develop this bishop on c1 right well we
see a hole on b3 we would like to play
b3 but okay maybe we cannot even take it
immediately I think we probably can
because there's ideas with Knight d4
later something like this for example
although the tactics have not been very
good for me recently but I think
something like this works so we see we
see this hole on b3 and if we go back to
nine to c3 my question first of all is
what's White's main setup here this is
not only in this position but in this
position it makes even more sense in the
normal Banco gambit given that the
Knights on a5 if you could make let's
say two three moves that wide which
moves to your play yep
b3 Bishop to b2 again b3 limiting this
Knight Bishop to b2 is nice and one
thing that we always want to watch out
for when we play b3 is that black
doesn't play c4 and get counter play so
preferably something with the rook on b1
for example so that when he plays c4 we
either have the rook already looking
towards the black queen
or we can play b4 which is really our
idea alright because then again night to
b7 that's normally not good for black so
exactly b3 Bishop to b2 and you will
find that in the Bangko a gambit line
with where y place with g3 not the main
line but this is also the main idea with
the knight on 85 it's even more obvious
so next question every single moves the
question now we really come to your
point do we go Bishop to a7 do we go
Bishop to d7 or do we play Bishop to f5
again couple of minutes if you have any
questions in the meantime feel free to
ask I knew that question was coming
Bishop to f5 Bishop to d7 Bishop to e6
okay mishit the a61 very good this is
the d7 one to Bishop f5
okay yours yours you're still stuck with
Bishop a6 okay okay great
good okay so no okay that's that's fine
let's go to your move first with the a6
so imagine I go route to be one now
let's play a couple moves over here now
because really Bishop to a6 is one of
the most natural moves into position
okay the thing about playing c4 before I
have played b3 or really anything that
you can attack is that I might just not
go b3 at all anymore so I'm going to
play for example Knight to f3 I'm
considering to go E for sometimes it
depends how easily you have access to
the square right if you can jump like
this or even better with your b7 night I
will probably not do it but the bigger
issue here is that and I'm just going to
make a couple sample moves to try and
prove my point
if I get my knight to d4 and to c6
things can get very unpleasant so
imagine something like this you're happy
you're getting to c5 but what's next not
so clear right I mean there might be
tricks there might be 93 but if white
controls this position play something
like h3 Bishop e3 slowly Knight to c6
it's really us who gave away more
important squares more than anything and
last but not least we still have to take
in to come B 4 and B 3 at all times so
playing c4 is nice it gives us more
space but it also well most of all it
gives away the d4 square right so c4
it's not really a move I would recommend
playing if
right so maybe c4 after he plays b3 so
let's play rook to b8 right this is the
position adding layer and probably
thought about before he came to this
game before prepared his opening line
this type of position the game gather
against Vladimir of 1958 I I was just
reading this part I don't know that much
but what's what I do know is that again
you want to play c4 now what I was
talking about order earlier happens b4
night - b7 while we see that we're being
dominated right b5 for I think
immediately loses a piece but the
problem is really that unless lights
playing Bishop to b2 at the wrong moment
and then we can play c4 we got some
activity it's going to be very hard to
come up with a plan here now this is
something that maybe some of the good
bulgur players or Bangor gambit players
will disagree with they'll say this is
fine this is playable but most players
don't like these positions for black so
that's the reason Bishop to a6 is not
such a great move it really puts us in a
typical Volga backgammon position I
would say even with the 1985 it's a
little worse than that now who had
Bishop to d7 Bishop to d7 is also again
it's it's actually facing the same type
of issue rook to be one route to be a b3
you could build a case that the bishop
is better on d7 you could say it's worse
I'm not quite sure I just don't see how
we're dealing with the same issue over
here so that leads us to the game yes
okay well you know I'm always there with
a nice question for you to answer
so Bishop to f5 was played efore and
here you are with your next question
very nice right I mean Robin comes to
the lecture he's like hey guys let's
give away a pawn it's great it's good
and then he lets you answer all the
questions yourself but this is the next
question
efore and believe me we're not going to
go through every single move with a new
question but this is just a very
important stage of the game to
understand what how did this guy even
improve on what was already known at the
time so e for the logical move we really
have to play this is why and now Bishop
the c8 Bishop to d7 anyway or Bishop to
g4 Bishop to g4 is a funny move but it
could you could maybe argue h3 or f3 or
both slightly weakening the bishops
active on g4 if he doesn't kick it away
Bishop d7 once again it's an active
square and bishop CA the last option
okay Bishop to d7 Bishop the c8 Bishop
to g4 okay if you have Bishop to g4 with
the idea of going Bishop c8 a move later
you've pretty much got the right idea
except that h3 is more of a useful move
for white than anything else
Bishop the CA is the right idea because
what you already mentioned the d3 Square
and to prove my points to really bring
this back to the basics we're going to
go really quickly and compare this to a
normal bulgur gambit so let's do this
really quickly let's go to a normal
Volga gambit why is it such a peculiar
situation compared to what is the normal
line so let's have a look the normal
Volga gambit over here if Y decides to
play with g3 over here you will never
see him play e4 and we are forced to
take on a6 with our Bishop by theory now
if Y does decide to play with E for he
pretty much exclusively place it here
and exchanges these bishops so what is
my point is that the bishop on e6 is
actually very useful if weif decides to
exchange it off much later by going
Bishop one back well then let's start
counting who lost more moves right and
with the pawn a four as we'll see in the
game you really get into some troubles
with white some annoying decisions so
Bishop to c8 was played very good for
those who found it the idea is to go to
a6
finally and white played h3 now h3 to me
is a very logical move because neither
g4 is very often an annoying idea of um
Knight to g4 is annoying because there's
also Bishop to d4 so not only is the
knight moving to e5 there's also perhaps
which is a D for attacking f2 and
normally this rook wants to move at some
point especially when bishops coming to
a6 o h3 it's an understandable move to
me
Bishop to a6 rook to d1 and if you're
very clever you may have seen answer I
hope not three moves again how do we
play this position guys rook to b8 pay
attention rook to b8 Knight to c4 or
Knight to d7 yes
rook to b8 Knight to c4 Knight to d7
again they're all logical moves but one
is better than the other
all of them are moves that you would
like to play with which one first Knight
to d7 really everyone her BA okay the
idea the point is really that the
difference between Ruby 8 and 9 to d7 is
quite you know small Knight to c4 would
not be a very good idea because of
Knight to a4 not so hard I mean if we're
moving over here then I think we're
getting pins if I'm not mistaken so not
the best move and I wrote the b8 is for
sure we want to play this move it's part
of our setup 97 to me is slightly better
because we're keeping this or actually
we're introducing this idea of 95 which
is a d3 right away or as with the Ruby 8
he doesn't immediately have to think
about this but in all fairness the
difference is very very small
why place Knight to f3 because 95 is
really quite annoying black plays Knight
to c4 now what is the idea if I go b3
that's kind of the move that we are
always afraid of right
why can't you go be three
now the e5 is is fine but it's not
necessarily a huge achievement on our
part imagine get something like this and
he goes for Ruby one or but should be
too okay even then let's say Bishop to
b2 maybe you can you can play c4 will
change the bishops I'll be a pawn up and
we'll see if you can equalize it the c3
Knight exactly now what's the best way
to do that
Queen a5 or may be even more aggressive
Queen to b4 right and we see actually a
legitimate problem over here if we just
take on c4 which is kind of the given
move because it's not so easy to protect
against the threats here if we take then
black is already much better because the
a pawn is also about to be lost and for
that reason why play book to be one
Queen to be for anyway again very clever
good timing actually because what
happens after a three which is kind of
the logical move here take the a3 pawn
exactly take the a3 pawn and we've won
our pawn back this one is always weaker
than the one on c5 and this is typically
quite a lot better for black yeah
alright so Queen to b4
again it's really annoying we can't
really move we want to play b3 we can we
want to play a three weekend we'd like
to go Bishop d2 but who really wants to
trade that Bishop for our you know the
bad knives basically the knife came from
a5 to c4 and our Bishop c1 Bishop is
virtually our best piece so again it's
all it all has its drawbacks
why decides to go for Bishop to f1
prefers to give perhaps the bishop on c4
under the right circumstances ok now we
finally play route to b8 well I decided
to take take and play Bishop to g5 next
question so our p7 pawn is under attack
we can play f6 we can play King f8 or we
can play Bishop takes c3 the nice
positional Bishop Bishop takes c3
so again a couple minutes and when you
make your decision I also would like to
have kind of a evaluation
do you like blacks position at this
point or do you feel like white is still
pawn up and doing well okay
yes you play King f8 who else wants to
go King f8 King f8 is basically the
positionally very sound way to defend
East 7 right because f6 we really don't
want to play if you had f6 unfortunately
not not the right move it's blocking
your Bishop and yeah it just doesn't do
much for your position King f8 this is a
good move because it retains most of the
threats again you're a pawn down but
really this is quite quite a successful
banker gambit I mean even if he goes not
to d2 for example we can go Queen d3
it's still very hard for white to to
move we could think about doubling on
the B file increasing the pressure great
who had a better move go head Bishop
takes c3 nobody yes
okay so Bishop takes c3 was playing the
game it's a very strong move but it has
a very tactical reason what is the
reason behind very good question why
can't he take with the Queen we take
with the Queen will take on c3 and we
still sharp
this late in evening
taking and Bishop Bishop e2 exactly
Bishop to e2 and these two are hanging
this is much better for black you can
also play f6 first to make sure you can
take on e7 at all
Bishop moves anywhere basically Bishop
to e2 and we're winning in exchange
we're going to win the a2 pawn as well
it's pretty much over so we're forced to
play B takes c3 and what's blacks move
now yeah
Queeny - exactly in the same style once
again if we take bishop takes
we're losing material right so what we
see Bishop takes c3 I wouldn't say it's
very typical in these types of
structures but it's not completely
abnormal either because even if we do
manage to let's say get a structure like
this very often if we for example can
get our Bishop this c4 or something like
that this a pawn can just be lost very
easily right it becomes very weak so if
white is forced to go B takes c3 you'd
be surprised how often black has this
opportunity to play Bishop takes c3 okay
Queen takes Queen to e2 92 is almost
forced because we need to protect the
night as well Knight 2 e1 we would love
to play but it fails to the nice queen
to f1 check King h2 and Bishop to e2
rook is hanging pawn is hanging we see
that suddenly things can get very
tactical we've made all these nice
positional choices and White has played
a couple of odd moves let's say Sun
needs full tactics that's really typical
for the structure I would say you need
to do you need to be able to do both
Knight d2
like late Knight to e5 another very nice
move introducing this idea of Knight f3
using the pin y2 combi 8 to convey 8
plate Queen to a4 so the idea is that if
we go Bishop to b5 which looks very
logical he is going to pin us with Queen
to b3 and it's not so easy to get out of
this so maybe it looked to be one even
on the next move and let's say our
initiative is put on a halt for now
instead black played f6 and again I
really like this concept with Bishop
takes c3 and f6 specifically because as
you can see we're playing against this
Bishop over here of course the position
is very tactical but the idea that our
pawns are blocking is Bishop whereas our
Bishop is still absolutely free able to
go to d3 e2 all these nice squares is
again something that is worth keeping in
mind because it can get
even more compensation for your pawn
Bishop to e3 now it's pretty clear that
black has a very serious initiative
we're still down upon but if you're not
happy with blacks position at this point
is probably not the right opening for
you
so next question Bishop to d3 King to f7
or H 5 H 5 value of H for opening up the
position a little bit Bishop d3 well
clearly putting a lot more pressure
specifically on the e pawn and King to
f7 just kind of a useful move to
safeguard the King a little bit more if
you've been doing very poorly then this
is your chance because this is the last
question who knows maybe he blundered
yeah black one very soon after this and
you black should win very soon after it
so make sure you get this move right
everyone yeah okay so perfect that can
someone tell me how to solve this
position because what I like to do
especially when it comes to positions in
which it's clear that I have to find
quite precise moves in which I'm
building up an advantage and I wouldn't
say necessarily that here it's only time
bound but we still upon down we don't
want to give Y too much time to
recuperate from this position maybe
player okay one Queen d1 try to get our
clean out and so on so the question I
would ask myself in this position is
which piece do I need to strengthen my
attack as much as possible now if you
ask yourself this question you would
have come to the conclusion ship like
king to f7 not because you want to
include your King into the attack but
because we want to play rook to B -
which is very logical rook to be - just
increases the pressure all over it puts
pressure on the a pawn all kinds of
threats but we cannot play it right now
check and we're getting in trouble right
now the other moves are decent too it's
just that I don't know exactly what my
next move is over here right go ahead
Bishop to d3 okay what is your next move
what's your idea what is y going to play
ad so it's actually still not an easy
position of course but okay can I do I
have time for something like Bishop to
f4 perhaps where is that already falling
for some concrete trick knife three
check anyway
yeah and rook to e1 now I have some
dreams like maybe Queen d7 Queen here or
something like yeah exactly I mean like
I said I think black still has a huge
advantage after Bishop d3 most likely
but it's not as conceptual skiing f7
king f7
mm-hm exactly all the counterplay relays
are Queenie eight and so on because
really our rook is great on b8 but in
order to finish this game we need it on
b2 so rook to be to a king to f7 was
played quite plate Queen c2 stopping
rugby to but now Knight to f3 check
Bishop d3 look at this these players at
this level they of course they consider
a move like nighty 1 but actually after
taking taking again we're much better
but let's say he's able to play c4 it's
technically speaking not so different
I'm not so easy here because he sort of
got rid of our most important attacking
pieces our route doesn't have easy and
entrance right now so he goes Bishop to
d3 first Queen goes back and just takes
a very nice way to round it up because
after Bishop takes Bishop takes e4 check
the Queen's coming in and here we see of
course that opposite color Bishop stay
they do give some effect
since they're not only draw tools after
rook takes what is black play
queen of one Czechia and exactly after
king edge to rule to be one again we see
how useful this move was King f3 he
actually resigned after after this move
of King f3 something like check even I'm
picking up this pawn it's it's almost
made already so for example King here I
guess you can easily take and it should
should be a maid soon so let's go
through the game one more time briefly
and see what exactly was so awesome
about this game because I I really am a
big fan of this game I think it for me
really changed my perception of the
whole Bank of gambit structure and how I
look at it first of all the point of
giving up a pawn then losing a tempo a
full tempo just to provoke efore I think
it's very impressive this is not the
type of idea you're going to see you
know given by the computer or something
like that and really I have a lot of
respect for ding leer and for coming up
with such a concept then following up
very nicely Bishop 286 97 95 and we saw
it actually later on his pro his point
was completely proven when arguably of
course white can play better but it was
really proven when White was playing
this move Bishop to f1 later on what is
really important to remember if you go
in and play this type of position is
that it's all about b3 group and Bishop
to b2 if you're playing this is black
and white can safely do this and maybe
in combination with rook people work to
b1 maybe not you probably did it wrong
because as soon as Y it gets rid of the
bishop on c1 it can develop naturally we
started in a game it went to g5 but he
had to give up a bishop first you had to
make all kinds of concessions if he can
play this he's neutralizing the pressure
on the Queen side which is really what
we're playing for and that's more or
less it we were going to have to wait
and sit there and a lot of banco players
do win games like that as well because
it's very tricky we always have active
play as soon as you come forward with
white it's you know also dangerous
because there are so many pieces on the
board but really what Dingley ran showed
in this game is that he could prevent it
by very positional means and of course
the moment that the tactic started he
was a great player and he finishes off
in style moves like king f7
quite easy to him I imagine but not so
easy when you have to make that switch
from very positional play almost like
you're not down upon at all to very
tactical so this was the quiz if you did
well good for you if you didn't if you
didn't then please have another look at
the game because it's a very nice one
I'd like to just say it's not my quiz
it's a part of what used to be chess
fives now is chess calm it's written by
my good Dutch friend Ryan from the elves
before I get you know people asking why
didn't you give me credit so it's not
mine but I used to work for a project
that makes these quizzes so I hope you
liked it if you have any questions
please feel free to ask because it's not
such an easy game to understand I think
and yeah thank you